[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
WE'RE JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD CARILLO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
A REAL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY A GUEST CHAPLAIN
HIS EMINENCE.
METROPOLITAN JURASSIC MOST OF
SAN FRANCISCO AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
--
THIS FOR A ON THIS DAY WE BOW
OUR HEADS TO GIVE THANKS. TO OUR
LOVING AND MERCIFUL GOD
[inaudible] FOUR FREEDOMS.
WITH THE WHICH WELL BLESSED.
AND TO CELEBRATE OUR UNITY IN
THE EVENT A CITY.
OZ VISITS THEME TO BODY PREPARES
FOR THIS DELIBERATIONS.
MAY THEY BE ENLIGHTENED BY THE
POWER.
UPLIFTED BY YOUR GRACE.
AND GRANTED STRENGTH AND WISDOM --
IS THE LEAD THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WOULD BE SEATED ZERO TO STRETCH
FORTH YOU MIGHT THE HEAD AND AND
PROTECT THOSE WHO SELL THEIR CD.
STATE INCOME THREE WITH DIGNITY
AND SELFLESSNESS.
THAT THE SOUL THE WAYS TO BE
MINDFUL THAT WE ARE ALL MADE.
IN YOUR IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
AND THE THE AUCTIONS TOWARDS ONE
ANOTHER.
SHOULD BE MOTIVATED BY PEACE AND
LOVE.
MAY THE VALUES UPON WHICH THIS
COUNTRY [inaudible]
WAS FOUNDED.
INSPIRE YOU NEED THEIR SLEEP.
WITH GOD'S PRESENCE.
AS ECHO INSTEAD THE GUIDE AN
INSPIRATION FOR YOUR WORK --
THEN.
MEMBERS I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO
THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES
[inaudible]
LOCAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR WILL BE
INVITED TO JOIN US ON THE FLOOR
FOR TODAY'S FLOOR SESSION.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO START WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
S. R. NINETEEN SENATOR BOARD
JUST ARE YOU PREPARED.
SENATOR BORDERS AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION NINETEEN
BY SENATOR PORGES RELATIVE TO
GREEK INDEPENDENCE DAY.
SENATOR BOARD AS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT -- MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SENATE RESOLUTION
NINETEEN COMMEMORATING GREEK
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
A NATIONAL HOLIDAY CELEBRATED ON
MARCH TWENTY FIFTH COMMEMORATING
THE START OF THE GREEK
INDEPENDENCE MOVEMENT. FOR
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED YEARS GREECE
WAS UNDER THE RAIN. FOR ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS GREECE WAS
UNDER THE REIGN OF THE OTTOMAN
EMPIRE THROUGHOUT THIS PERIOD
THE GREEK ORTHODOX CHURCH PLAYED
A PIVOTAL ROLE IN THE
PRESERVATION OF NATIONAL
IDENTITY.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF GREEK SOCIETY
AND THE RESURGENCE OF GREEK
PATRIOTISM.
THE GREEK REVOLT BEGAN ON MARCH
TWENTY FIFTH EIGHTEEN TWENTY ONE
WHEN BISHOP -- YOUR MONO SO PAPA
RAISE THE GREEK FLAG OF ROPE OF
REVOLUTION IN THE BELLY BONUSES
THE PELOPONNESE.
JUST AS THE REVOLUTION APPEARED
TO BE ON THE VERGE OF FAILURE.
GREAT BRITAIN FRANCE AND RUSSIA
INTERVENE IN THE CONFLICT.
THE GREEK STRUGGLE HAD ELICITED
STRONG SYMPATHY IN EUROPE
INCLUDING AMONGST INTELLECTUALS
AND ARTISTS SUCH AS THE ENGLISH
POET LORD BYRON.
THE REVOLUTION ENDED IN EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINE WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN INDEPENDENT
GREEKS STATE.
GREEK INDEPENDENCE DAY IS MORE
THAN JUST ESTABLISHING AN
INDEPENDENT GREEK STATE.
IT IS ALSO ABOUT THE LASTING
VALUES IN CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
HELLENISM HAS BROUGHT TO THE
WORLD.
THE UNITED STATES AND OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA.
IN LAW EDUCATION AND DEMOCRACY
GREEK INFLUENCES CAN BE FOUND
EVERYWHERE.
EVEN THE COLUMNS ON THE EXTERIOR
OF THIS BUILDING.
DERIVED THE ROOTS FROM A GREEK
ARCHITECTURE.
IN OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE GREEK
HERITAGE.
GREEK CULTURE IS ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED MY LIFE.
MY FAMILY AND MY WIFE'S FAMILY
ARE BOTH FROM GREECE.
I CONDUCTED SO MY GRADUATE
STUDIES AND WAS A FULBRIGHT
SCHOLAR IN GREECE.
YEAH I'M HERE TODAY THE CONSUL
GENERAL PERSONALLY ADMINISTERED
MY OATH FOR MY PHD.
AND MIND YOU THAT WAS IN ANCIENT
GREEK.
REALLY TOUGH I GOTTA TELL YOU.
SO AS GREECE OF THE UNITED
STATES CONTINUE TO STAND
TOGETHER AS FRIENDS AND ALLIES
LET US RECOGNIZE OUR LOVE FOR
FREEDOM.
LIBERTY AND INDIVIDUAL RIGHTS.
AND ALLOW THIS RESOLUTION TO BE
A GESTURE RECOGNIZING THE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS GREECE
HAS MADE AND CONTINUES TO MAKE
IN OUR GOLDEN STATE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS RUMORS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
HI.
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
HI WE'RE JUST.
HI BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER.
BY CHIANG BY DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK [inaudible]
I'M RAIL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
BY PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
I WALK OUT SEE I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
THE REPORT IS DID YOU WANT TO
INTRODUCE A GUEST YES WITH THE
THE PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE A NUMBER OF
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS IF I MAY --
STARTING OFF FIRST WITH THE THE
HONORABLE -- AND ANTONIO'S SO
GOOD OPEN LOS THE CONSUL GENERAL
OF GREECE IN SAN FRANCISCO MR
SOCORRO COLOSSUS SERVED AS
DEPUTY HEAD OF THE DIPLOMATIC
OFFICE OF THE GREEK PRESIDENT IN
SINCE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HAS LED THE SAN
FRANCISCO CONSULATE WE'RE
PRIVILEGED TO BE JOINED BY THE
CONSUL GENERAL TODAY.
ALSO HIS EMINENCE METROPOLITAN I
GET US IN MOST METROPOLITAN TO
GET US THE MOST WAS BORN IN
GREECE AND MOVED TO THE UNITED
STATES WHERE HE STUDIED AT THE
HOLE IN THE COLLEGE IN BROOKLINE
MASSACHUSETTS.
HE WAS ELECTED BY THE HOLY AND
SACRED SYNNOT OF THE ECUMENICAL
PATRIARCHATE -- IT TO BE THE
METROPOLITAN OF SAN FRANCISCO IT
HAS SERVED THIS CAPACITY SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE WE ARE HONORED
BY HIS PRESENCE AND WELCOME YOUR
EMINENCE -- LASTLY OR SECOND
LESS HIS FATHER A TELUS FATHER
JAMESWERE TELUS IS THE PRIEST
OF THE ANNUNCIATION GREEK
ORTHODOX CHURCH IN SACRAMENTO.
HE IS HEAVILY INVOLVED IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE ARE HONORED TO
HAVE HIM JOIN US TODAY.
AND LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE.
OUR VERY OWN PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE OUR LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR A
LADY COULD A LAKIS MY VERY GOOD
FRIEND AND FELLOW MEMBER OF THE
GREEK CAUCUS.
WE ARE A BIPARTISAN -- CAUCUS OF
TWO BUT WE ARE TAKING AN OPEN
FOR MEMBERSHIP BEYOND THAT IF WE
HAVE SOME -- FILL HELEN'S IN
THERE.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU YOUR
FAMILY FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE
PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR TO SAY A FEW
WORDS.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM SENATE
PRO TEM THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SENATOR MEMBERS OF THE ESTEEMED
BODY OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE IT IS AN HONOR AS ALWAYS
TO BE HERE.
I SENATOR BOARD JUST DID A GREAT
JOB IS SORT OF FRAMING THE AYE
THE REVOLUTION AND THE WAR FOR
INDEPENDENCE IN GREASE BUT SINCE
GREEK INDEPENDENCE DAY HAPPENS
TO FALL WITHIN WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO REMEMBER THE
GREEK NAVAL COMMANDER AND HERA
WHEN OF THE GREEK WAR OF
INDEPENDENCE LAST ARENA -- LENA.
AT AGE FORTY ON THE ISLAND OF
SPATS SAYS -- BELINA BECAME A
WIDOW AND INHERITED HER
HUSBAND'S FORTUNE AND HIS
TRADING BUSINESS.
SHE COMMITTED THAT FORTUNE TO
THE COST OF INDEPENDENCE
CONVERTING HER TRADING SHIPS TWO
WARSHIPS.
AND BUILT ONE OF GREECE'S
LARGEST WARSHIPS THE AUGMENTED
NINE RIGHT UNDER THE NOSES OF
AUTUMN AN OFFICIAL.
WHEN THE REVOLUTION BROKE OUT
SHE HERSELF COMMANDED THE
AUGMENTIN INTO BATTLE?
THEY SET A BOOBY LINA WAS THE
FIRST WOMAN IN HISTORY EVER TO
HOLD THE TITLE ADMIRAL.
AND HER NAME FOR GREEKS AND
GREEK AMERICANS ALIKE IS THE
TERM USED FOR A WOMAN OF COURAGE
CONVICTION.
AND DETERMINATION.
I WILL ADMIT MY OWN GRANDFATHER
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL CALLED
ME A BOO BOO LENA.
AND I ALWAYS STROVE TO LIVE UP
TO THAT NAME.
THANK YOU SENATOR BOARD JUST FOR
BRINGING US TOGETHER TO REMEMBER
AND CELEBRATE GREEK INDEPENDENCE
THE SHARED VALUES BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND THE WHOLE ANNEKE
REPORT REPUBLIC.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF GREEK
HISTORY TO GREEK AMERICANS AND
TO THE WORLD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
AND YOUR GUESTS WILL COME TO
YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
.
CENTER BOARD YES MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU ONE LAST -- COMMENT ON
HIS PROCEED MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
EVERYONE HEARS AWARE THAT YOU
ARE ALL INVITED TO HAVE A A A
SMALL COMMEMORATIVE COFFEE WITH
OUR STEAM GUESS IT'S GONNA BE
RIGHT OVER HERE.
TO ELEVEN UPON A GERMAN TO OF OF
OF OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY SO
PLEASE -- MAKE YOURSELVES
AVAILABLE BE WONDERFUL TO HAVE
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
BORCHERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
ON THIS ITEM MR SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR S. R. [inaudible]
NINETEEN ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI. THIRTY SEVEN ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
SENATOR GLAZER.
DID YOU HAVE.
ANNOUNCEMENT.
THAT OUT -- SO SORRY
[inaudible] ONE MOMENT
[inaudible]
GOOD
.
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
GLAZER.
AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS HI
THERE IS.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS ARE SO
MUCH THE THAT WE'RE PROUD OF
ABOUT CALIFORNIA -- AND ONE OF
THE PLACES THAT I KNOW WE TAKE
RIGHT GREAT PRIDE IN IS THE
GREAT GROWING REGIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR STATE.
I KNOW MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
FROM MY NAPA.
FROM MY THE CARMEL VALLEY.
EVEN FROM TO MACULA.
TALK OFTEN ABOUT THE GREAT WINES
THAT ARE MADE -- IN THEIR AREA.
AND CERTAINLY A LOT OF THAT IS
PRIDE AND IT'S ALSO A MATTER OF
OPINION.
BUT THROUGH THE COURSE OF
HISTORY SOMETIMES THAT OPINION
GETS CHALLENGED.
AND WE OF COURSE REMEMBER THE
FAMOUS PARRIS TASTINGS THAT.
CALIFORNIA WINES COMPETE AGAINST
THE GREATEST WINES IN THE WORLD.
IN PARIS AND WE KNOW THE RESULTS
OF THAT -- AND THEIR MIDDLE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WITH
CALIFORNIA COMING.
AHEAD.
SO THERE'S OPINION ABOUT WINE
AND THEN THERE'S THE EXPERTS
WHAT THE EXPERTS SAY ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF THE GRAPES OF THE
GROUND.
LASER ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE
THE FOLKS AT THE BACK OF
CHAMBERS TAKE THEIR
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED CENTER GLAZER SO
ONE OF THE GREATEST WINE
COMPETITIONS IN THE WORLD.
IS HELD HERE IN CALIFORNIA BY
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE.
LAST YEAR THEY TASTED SIX
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED LINES
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD WITH
SIXTY FOUR PROFESSIONAL JUDGES.
AND IN THAT CASE TING THE
IDENTIFIED THE BEST WINES WITHIN
EACH VARIETAL.
CABERNET.
MERLOT.
WONDERFUL GRAPES ARE GROWN THEY
SAID WHICH WERE THE BEST IN
THOSE CATEGORIES IN THE HONORED
THEM ACCORDINGLY.
BUT AT THE END OF THAT CONTEST
THEY SAID LET'S TAKE ALL THE
BEST OF THE BEST AND LET'S RATE
THEM AGAINST EACH OTHER.
AND PICK THE SWEEPSTAKES WINNERS.
THE NINE BEST WINES OF THE OVER
SIX THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
SUBMITTED.
AND I'M PLEASED TO HAVE YOUR ON
THE FLOOR.
THE WINNER OF THE SWEEPSTAKES
COMPETITION.
IT'S A WINERY -- THAT IS LOCATED
IN THE LIVERMORE VALLEY A
GROWING A CLAIM AREA -- IN OUR
STATE AND CERTAINLY IN MY
DISTRICT.
AND THEY AWARDED THE SWEEPSTAKES
TO A BOTTLE OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN MALL BACK.
BY THE LOS PROCEED AS VINEYARDS
A LIVER MORE ONE HERE TO
RECOGNIZE THEM ON THE FLOOR -- I
WANT TO NOTE THAT THEY WERE KIND
ENOUGH TO BRING A BOTTLE OF
THEIR TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN MALL
BACK.
HERE TO THE SENATE AND THERE'S A
SPECIAL TASTING IN MY OFFICE
FOLLOWING THE FLOOR IF YOU LIKE
TO COMBINE TRY THAT.
SPECIAL UP WINE AND WITH THAT
MEMBERS PLEASE WELCOME THEM
CORRECTLY THEM ON THEIR SUCCESS
HERE THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
WE ARE STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR SENATOR HER TADO
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF FOR
THE PURPOSE OF INTRODUCTION I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT A GROUP
OF YOUNG WOMAN THAT.
ARE UP THERE FROM JOHN MUIR
MIDDLE SCHOOL YOUR YOUNG
SCIENTIST.
FROM THE CITY OF CORCORAN.
WELCOME TO HAVE A LOCK IN THE
RATE SENATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR TADO.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO DEMAND
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
ALSO BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FOUR MINUTES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
A ONE S. C. R. EIGHT SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO TEN
WITH THE MOMENTS. TWO THIRTY TO
AT THE MOMENT SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY WITH AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY THE
SECOND READING FILE HAS BEEN
READ.
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS SENATOR
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FORCE A
CONFIRMATION OF CHAIRED
BLUMENFELD AS SECRETARY THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY.
MR BLUMENFELD IS THE FOUNDER OF
ADVISING IMPACT HE PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS A REGIONAL
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST AT THE U. S.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY.
AND AS DIRECTOR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF
ENVIRONMENT.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH THIRTEENTH ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WORLD MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
BOB HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY HI I WINNER BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
OUR TOP [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LUCK.
I THIRTY TWO KNOWS THREE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
IT'S A CONFIRMATION OF JULIE SU
AS SECRETARY OF THE LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
MISS SUE HAS MANY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN LABOR LAW AND
ENFORCEMENT.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT SHE
SIR FOR EIGHT YEARS AS LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
VOTE IN THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
MARCH THIRTEENTH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WILL MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI TODD.
BY THE RAZA.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
THE RAIL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I LIKE OWSKI.
I WINNER.
BY WILK HI.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
GROWTH [inaudible]
MARLA [inaudible]
HI.
MORRELL.
I TO KNOW. FIVE THIRTY THREE
KNOWS TO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO SENATE THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU FARM TWELVE SENATOR
LEYVA PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SENATOR BELL.
SENATOR BILL DO YOU WISH TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN SENATE BILL WHICH I
TAKE A PASS ON FILE THAT
COMPLETES OUR THIRD READING WILL
MAIL ROUTE MOVE MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SENATOR JONES.
THIRD JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN A VERY GOOD MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLOOR RELATIVE TO COLORECTAL
CANCER AWARENESS MONTH SENDER
JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- NO IN DECEMBER OF
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHEN MY
THIRD.
CHILD WAS -- EIGHT MONTHS OLD.
I RECEIVED THOSE THREE WORDS
THAT NONE OF US WANT TO HEAR.
YOU HAVE CANCER.
NOW FORTUNATELY FOR ME AT THE
TIME THE CANCER THAT I HAD WAS
VERY EASILY TREATABLE.
AND IS PERMANENTLY CURABLE.
BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE FOR
EVERYBODY.
AND SO -- ACR THIRTY TWO TODAY.
RECOGNIZES MARCH IS COLORECTAL
CANCER AWARENESS MONTH.
COLORECTAL CANCER IS THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF CANCER DEATHS
IN CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER IT IS TREATABLE CURABLE
AND IN MOST CASES COMPLETELY
PREVENTABLE.
IT HAS A 90% SURVIVAL RATE WHEN
DETECTED EARLY.
COLORECTAL CANCER SCREENING IS
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PREVENTION MAJORS IN HEALTH CARE.
PROPER SCREENING IS ESSENTIAL
FOR PREVENTION AND EARLY
DETECTION.
AND TREATMENT BY INCREASING
SCREENING RATES.
WE CAN REDUCE INCIDENT AT DEATH
RATES DRASTICALLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THE USER JONES.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR ISSUES
MAY NOT QUESTIONS BUT DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AND AT MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
I KNOW MANY OF US THINK OF
FRIENDS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE
CANCER IN ITS DIFFERENT FORMS
AND CERTAINLY.
UP FOR ME -- FOR THE LAST COUPLE
DAYS -- FRIEND OF MANY HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE HAS HAD THAT
DIAGNOSIS OF THIS TYPE OF CANCER.
I KNOW OUR BEST WISHES GO OUT TO
HER AND SHE FIGHTS HARD -- TO TO
GET THROUGH IT -- BUT I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK TO
BRING AWARENESS TO THIS AND WE
CERTAINLY.
SEND OUR BEST WISHES TO ALL
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN AFFLICTED.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING MANSER JONES
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WHILE I HAD --
THYROID CANCER WHICH IS ONE OF
THE EASIEST CANCERS TO TREAT
THIS ALSO IS A PREVENTABLE AND
CURABLE AND TREATABLE IF
PROPERLY SCREENED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AGAIN I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BELL.
BY FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA HI BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
HI MY COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
CENTER HER TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
PURPOSES OF ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AT THREE PM.
THANK YOU CENTER HER TACO WE'RE
NOW RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A GERMAN
AND MEMORIES SENATOR WIENER DID
YOU HAVE AN INTERNAL MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TO
RETURN.
WITH ACID THE SENATE ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY OF JAKE PHELPS -- A
SKATEBOARDING ICON SAN FRANCISCO
NATIVE -- AN EDITOR OF THE WORLD
RENOWNED MAGAZINE THRASHER
SKATEBOARDING MAGAZINE -- WHO
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY AT THE
AGE OF FIFTY SIX A WEEK AND A
HALF AGO?
FOUNDED IN -- NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE SAN FRANCISCO BASED THRASHER
MAGAZINE CONTINUES TO THIS DAY
AS A FORM FOR THE SKATEBOARDING
WORLD.
I KNOWS MUCH ABOUT SUCCESS -- TO
MISTER PHELPS WHO BECAME ITS
EDITOR IN -- NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
JAKE TOLD THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE REGARDING
SKATEBOARDING.
QUOTE IF PARENTS DON'T COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT WE'RE DOING SOMETHING
WRONG.
IT'S THE KIND OF THING YOU HIDE
UNDER YOUR BED AT NIGHT IT'S THE
RECKLESSNESS OF YOUTH AND QUOTE.
TONY VITELLO WHO IS THE CURRENT
OWNER OF THRASHER SAID OF FELTS
QUOTE HE ONLY KNEW COMMITMENT.
HE WAS GOING TO GO FOR IT
WITHOUT HESITATION AND THERE
WERE ONLY TWO OUTCOMES IF YOU
SEE HIS TRIUMPH AND FISTS
PUMPING IN THE AIR.
OR IT WOULD BE AN EARTH SHAKING
COLLISION WITH THE CONCRETE.
A HARD SKATING ICON OF THE
SKATEBOARDING WORLD IN THE
STREETS OF SAN FRANCISCO WELL
INTO HIS FIFTIES -- JAKE WOULD
BE SEEN FLYING DOWN THE MIDDLE
OF THE STREET.
FLIPPING OFF CARS AND TOURISTS
WHILE WORSHIPING THE HILLS OF
OUR GREAT CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
THAT GAVE HIM HIS LOVE OF
SKATEBOARDING.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME AND
INTERNING TODAY'S MEETING AND
MEMORY OBJECTS SELVES THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED.
CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I'M
HONORED TODAY TO JOIN I MEMORY
T. AND TO HONOR THE LIFE OF
ROBERT GAINES -- EIGHTY FOUR THE
FATHER OF OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
SENATOR TED GAINES.
ROBERT WAS A CALIFORNIA NATIVE
BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND GRADUATED
FROM BERKELEY HIGH SCHOOL.
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTEEN HE
JOINED THE UNITED STATES ARMY
AND SERVED AS A TAIL GUNNER ON A
BOEING.
B. SEVENTEEN IN WORLD WAR TWO
FLYING OVER THIRTY FIVE MISSIONS
IN GERMANY.
HE WAS HONORABLY DISCHARGED FROM
THE ARMY IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX
AND ENTERED UC BERKELEY ON THE
GI BILL WELL IT BERKELEY HE MET
HIS WIFE WINIFRED.
AND THEY WERE MARRIED IN
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE AND THEY HAD
SIX CHILDREN ROBERT WAS THE
ULTIMATE FAMILY MAN AND ALWAYS
LOVED HELPING OUT HIS FAMILY.
DIDN'T RUBBERS MILITARY SERVICE
HE DEVELOPED A GREAT LOVE FOR
THE LORD AND BECAME A DEVOUT
CHRISTIAN.
HE BECAME DEEPLY INVOLVED AT
TRINITY CATHEDRAL CHURCH IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE HE TAUGHT
SUNDAY SCHOOL PARTICIPATED EVERY
CHURCH Và ON THE CHURCH VESTRY
AND PROVIDED MINISTRY TO THE
SICK AND THE HOMEBOUND.
HE WAS ALSO AN ACTIVE MEMBER
SEVERAL CLUBS INCLUDING THE
SACRAMENTO ROTARY CLUB THE
SETTER CLUB AND THE GRANDFATHERS
CLUB.
ROBERT WAS A DEVOUT HUSBAND
FATHER GRANDFATHER FOLLOWER OF
CHRIST AND HE BELIEVED HE
BELIEVES BEHIND FIFTEEN GRAND.
FOUR GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
AND WE KNOW THE LEFT A GREAT
LEGACY OF SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY
WITH HIS COURAGEOUS SERVICE IN
THE UNITED STATES MILITARY.
AND IS COMMUNITY HE'S NOW
REUNITED WITH HIS WIFE IN HEAVEN
OUR LOVE AND SUPPORT GOES OUT TO
THE GAINES FAMILY AND I ASK YOU
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING
THE LIFE IN THE MEMORY OF ROBERT
GAINES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARDS WE CAN
PROBABLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY FURTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE BODY.
IF THERE IS NONE SENATOR.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
SENATE PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND AS A QUICK REMINDER
THERE IS THE RECEPTION -- IN
HONOR OF OUR GUESTS TODAY --
RELATED -- TO GREEK INDEPENDENT
STATE INTO ELEVEN AND OTHER THAN
THAT WE WILL RECONVENE I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE AN INCREDIBLY
BUSY WEEK -- WE CERTAINLY WANT
TO KEEP THE THOUGHTS OF OUR OUR
COLLEAGUE IN OUR GOOD FRIEND WHO
LOST HIS FATHER -- THIS WEEK --
FROM COSTA MESA TO OUR
COLLEAGUES -- BUT WE WILL
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY THE TWENTY
EIGHTH AT NINE AM SHARP THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY
AT NINE AM HAVE A GREAT DAY
EVERYONE